I have girlfriends who have had a lot of
children has been killed and I look at
their pain and the hurt on their faces
and I don't want that I don't want my
son to get caught up in the wrong
anything
Chantal o Davis is a recovering drug
addict who's currently unemployed
and the single mother of a six-year-old
named a Siddiq when I leave this earth I
wanted him to be established you know I
haven't have to depend on anybody I want
me to be able to to get a job when I
want him to go off to college but Xie na
Siddiq live in the impoverished city of
Camden New Jersey which is home to some
of the nation's lowest performing public
schools Canada Public Schools routinely
graduating single or low double-digit
numbers of kids from the comprehensive
high schools who could pass the state's
exit exam a lot of kids did came out of
Kandahar to know how to read and write
how did the kid get through the school
without the teacher knowing that they
couldn't read or write that's what I
couldn't understand you not I mean so I
don't want that for my children for her
part Davis hasn't shown herself to be
the most proactive parent last year a
Siddiq was enrolled in public pre-k but
Davis says she wasn't feeling well
enough to take him so ah Sadiq ended up
staying home and missing most of the
year today in an effort to better meet
the needs of kids like ah Sadiq Davis
the state of New Jersey is remaking
Camden's public school system in a way
that's not quite like anything that's
been tried before the reform centers run
three new public schools that opened
this year that are run by outside
organizations over the next several
years they'll gradually expand their
enrollment until they serve the majority
of kids in Camden one of the new schools
is Kipp Cooper Norcross which is getting
its own forty five million dollar
building that's slated to open next year
so what's different about these new
schools for one thing they have a lot
more autonomy basically they get the
higher their own people they get the
fire whoever they want to we're seeing
the district use the tactics of charter
schools to reform its own offerings
but they have one big thing in common
with traditional public schools they
take students from a catchment area so
if you live within our community you're
guaranteed a spot in our school and
that's actually significantly different
than it than a typical charter that can
pull from an entire city or an entire
county
thirty-four-year-old drew Martin who's
in charge at Kipp Cooper Norcross says
that this provides an opportunity to
rebut critics who claim that the only
reason charter schools perform so well
is that they attract the most involved
parents willing to make the effort to
look for better options for their kids
and that they push out the most
difficult students so that is no longer
gonna even be able to apply to us
because we actually we're gonna be using
the same practices that we've always
used but we're it's by law we're gonna
be required to take the kids around from
our sending area so nobody can say that
we're creaming Darrell Bradford says
that the fact that parents aren't
choosing to send their kids to these
schools is a major shortcoming to me
that removes the most powerful and
fundamental element which is that a
parent wakes up one day and wants
something better and has the right to go
get it critics of charter schools say
they rarely serve kids like ah Sadiq
Davis he was part of the first class at
Kipp Cooper Norcross but Chantal o Davis
continued to have difficulty getting him
to school and she even withdrew him
after a dispute with the administration
Davis is planning to re-enroll ASSA T
and since it's his own school drew
Martin says the door is open when he's
ready to return and that's what's
different
if Kipp Cooper Norcross were Charter
School Martin wouldn't be required to
take him back killing a neighborhood
school is like putting a knife into the
heart of a community that's wrong Diane
Ravitch is the best-known education
policy analyst to make this charge that
charter schools don't serve kids from
the most troubled homes coincidentally
in 2012 she suggested on her blog pretty
much exactly what's happening in Camden
today challenging Kipp to put an end to
suspicions that they were skimming
students and excluding low-performing
students by taking over an entire
district
adding Camden looks like a perfect
candidate for the challenge I don't
think it has anything to prove to Diane
Ravich if there were no residential
assignment somebody would be out at the
home of the
person in Camden trying to recruit their
kid into a school because the economics
of it like this because there's no
residential assignment you must make
sure that the child of the neediest
parent actually comes to the school oh
I'm excited about what's going on there
cabinet is monumentally better today
than it was even two years ago who runs
the schools matters but I think in an
ideal world there would be open
enrollment everywhere it's not I think
it's a scapegoat we had more money we
could hire this or do this it's become
fashionable to say oh it's a waste it's
a cesspool the problem is in what
happened once the money got